[Musica]
13 ottobre 2013 una data che non
dimenticherò mai nella vita io che sono
sempre stata appassionata di spazio e
astronomia quel giorno ho incontrato per
la prima volta un astronauta magari lo
riconoscerete è Paolo Nespoli
dell'agenzia spaziale Europea Esa che si
trovava a Bari in occasione del lancio
del suo nuovo libro così io ho
acquistato una copia del libro Gliel'ho
portata e Nespoli mi ha lasciato in
prima pagina una dedica
Arianna punta in alto
da allora io ho preso questa frase un
po' come il mio motto la mia guida me lo
sono persino tatuato su un braccio in
una forma molto simile da allora io non
ho mai smesso di puntare in alto
un po' di mesi dopo sono risultata tra i
vincitori di un piccolo contest dell'esa
il cui premio era la possibilità di
incontrare un nuovo astronauta questa
volta Luca Parmitano presso una delle
sedi dell'agenzia così io felicissima
sono andata a Roma presso la sede
italiana dell'esa e una volta rientrata
ho pubblicato sul mio profilo Facebook
un album con le foto più belle di
quell'evento e nella descrizione ho
scritto una cosa ben precisa che a
leggerla oggi dopo quasi dieci anni mi
fa sorridere anche un po' emozionare
Ice Wear One day
lo giuro io un giorno lavorerò lì
lì a Lesa
Avevo vent'anni e un obiettivo ben
preciso ma ero anche una ragazzina
insicura confusa su ciò che mi piacesse
davvero e su chi volesse diventare da
grande ed ero costantemente affiancata
da una compagna di vita che definirei
tanto sgradevole quanto Fedele
l'ansia
l'incontro con cui si Astronauti è
avvenuto in un periodo della mia vita Un
po' frenetico e intenso perché la
mattina studiavo all'università e la
sera e nei weekend lavoravo in un
planetario quello che c'è a Bari ero
costantemente sotto pressione e
costantemente in ansia ricordo in
particolare il momento in cui capii che
l'ansia si stava impadronendo di me
Siamo al mio primissimo spettacolo al
Planetario di Bari che è appena
terminato le persone stanno lasciando la
sala felice e soddisfatte Perché in
effetti lo spettacolo è andato bene ma
io non mi sento così io mi sento
completamente sfinita prosciugata di
ogni energia o il fiato corto mi brucia
terribilmente lo stomaco e a un certo
punto mi accorgo che le mie mani perdono
sangue
letteralmente le mie dita stanno
sanguinando questo perché per tutta la
durata dello spettacolo io non ho fatto
altro che togliermi la pelle dalle dita
per sfogare quest'ansia che ho dentro di
me
così dopo qualche giorno mia mamma mi
prende un attimo in disparte le mamme
notano tutto non gli si può nascondere
nulla eh E mi dice una cosa che mi fa
riflettere
Ma tu vuoi andare all'Agenzia spaziale
europea con quelle mani
fa anche un po' ridere vero tu da domani
vai da una psicologa
Ebbene non proprio l'indomani Ma in
effetti dopo qualche settimana è
iniziato il mio percorso con Adriana
l'obiettivo di questo percorso doveva
essere l'acquisizione di consapevolezza
E questa doveva essere di due tipi o di
due livelli se vogliamo un livello più
relativo al mio corpo e le sensazioni
fisiche che provo che chiamerò
consapevolezza corporea e un altro
livello più relativo alla mia persona
che chiamerò consapevolezza di
personalità
vi starete chiedendo quindi Che cos'è la
consapevolezza corporea è uno stato in
cui noi siamo pienamente padroni del
nostro corpo dei segnali che questo ci
invia e del loro significato Mi spiego
meglio quando io mi toglievo la pelle
dalle mani non ero consapevole di fare
quel gesto era un po' un automatismo un
po' come il battito cardiaco non
possiamo controllarlo quindi per
sviluppare questo tipo di consapevolezza
ho imparato a fare tre cose la prima è
stata imparare a notare il gesto
autodistruttivo E una volta individuato
dovevo soffermarmi a capire quale fosse
la causa che mi aveva portato fin lì
Ok Mi stavo togliendo la pelle da questo
dito Ok potrebbe essere perché sono in
ansia per l'esame di biochimica la
settimana prossima ottimo
secondo esercizio
rimandare il gesto al futuro
letteralmente prenderlo e spostarlo ad
un altro momento ricordo che la
psicologa me lo faceva fare anche
proprio con i gesti prendere il pensiero
e il gesto è spostarlo al futuro perché
il qui e ora il presente deve essere
libero io nel presente devo essere
pienamente concentrata su quello che sta
accadendo in questo momento
all'inizio lo spostavo di soli 30
secondi che poi sono diventati 60
secondi e poi 60 minuti e pian piano Ho
imparato a spostare il vizio dal mattino
alla sera e da lunedì al venerdì e di
settimana in settimana e pian piano nel
corso dei mesi ho smesso gradualmente di
farlo quasi del tutto
terzo esercizio la respirazione
diaframmatica nella vita di tutti i
giorni noi respiriamo gonfiando e
sgonfiando questa parte del corpo no il
petto il torace di fatto facciamo una
respirazione che si chiama toracica Ma
esiste un altro tipo di respirazione
Appunto quella diaframmatica che andando
a coinvolgere i muscoli addominali
pancia diaframma a stomaco e così via
permette di allentare le tensioni e di
farci sentire molto rilassati è un
esercizio che potreste mettere in
pratica Già da stasera per favorire il
sonno o magari anche prossimamente nel
caso in cui abbiate un colloquio di
lavoro importante e magari un esame
universitario un po' tosto
e fin qua tutto abbastanza pratico
passiamo Allora all'altro livello di
consapevolezza quello di personalità Beh
questo è qualcosa di più difficile da
raggiungere perché non si tratta di
qualcosa di fisico e materiale è tutto
nella tua testa ma è anche il tipo di
consapevolezza più prezioso da
raggiungere Perché ti permette di
cambiare radicalmente la visione che hai
della vita e l'approccio che hai nei
confronti delle sfide e delle difficoltà
e allora abbiamo due strategie La prima
è la pratica della gratitudine
Vi chiedo a questo punto di
aiutarmi di collaborare Quanti di voi
riescono a pensare in questo momento ad
almeno una cosa bella presente nella
propria vita vi chiedo di alzare la mano
l'altro anche io partecipo meraviglioso
Ci vorrebbe una foto dal palco Grazie e
diciamo che trovarne una che tra l'altro
sono molto grata di essere a Ischia
Questa è quella che ho che ho pensato e
trovarne una Diciamo che è abbastanza
facile ma io all'epoca dovevo trovarne 5
ogni giorno e ogni giorno dovevano
essere diverse sul mio diario della
gratitudine non potevo scrivere il
mercoledì le stesse cose che avevo
scritto il martedì è un esercizio
terribilmente difficile per una persona
che soffre di ansia perché tendiamo a
vedere tutto in maniera negativa il
futuro il presente quello che accade
attorno a noi noi stessi
seconda strategia una lista dei miei
punti di forza e allora per alzata di
mano Quanti di voi riescono a pensare ad
un proprio punto di forza una qualità
qualcosa in cui siete bravi un po' più
difficile un po' più timidi ma ce
l'abbiamo ottimo Beh magari posso
dirmene uno mio è solo una persona
generalmente molto entusiasta Ma magari
voi siete creativi organizzati
innovativi e così via All'inizio la mia
lista era molto povera Ne avevo due o
tre e pian piano nel corso di sei mesi
siamo arrivati ad una lista di circa 20
oggi io lavoro all'esame occupandomi di
comunicazione e organizzazione eventi e
in particolare Mi occupo della
comunicazione dei progetti universitari
e scolastici prodotti dall'esa e se sono
arrivata fin qui è merito di tutto il
percorso che vi ho descritto Anzi direi
che è stato proprio l'ingrediente
fondamentale
ogni giorno mi scrivono su Instagram
decine e decine di ragazzi per lo più
studenti universitari e mi fanno una
domanda
Ari ma come faccio ad arrivare in un
posto come l'agenzia spaziale europea
che devo fare
Questa è una domanda che può avere
molteplici risposte ognuna in base al
caso che mi si presenta di fronte alla
storia del ragazzo le sue possibilità ai
suoi sogni ma la verità è che la
risposta più sincera che io possa dare è
che quello che fa la differenza quello
che davvero ti distingue dagli altri è
la consapevolezza che hai di te stesso
In altre parole quello che voglio dire è
che non può esserci crescita
professionale senza una solida crescita
personale alla base Se volete crescere
come professionisti dovete prima
crescere come persone e questo lo potete
fare solo se lavorate ogni giorno per
diventare la versione migliore di voi
stessi se lavorate ogni giorno per
prendervi cura di voi e allora Qualunque
sia il vostro obiettivo o il vostro
sogno Stasera vi auguro di trovare la
possibilità e il coraggio di prendervi
cura di voi perché Credetemi avere la
giusta consapevolezza può portarvi molto
molto lontano persino tra le stelle
[Applauso]
[Musica]